five years in the AG's increased his
scoring average every year
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that may be the prettiest part of the
game here it is a no-man's land
[Applause]
Bendis friend
eurogreen and Marcus Morris let down on
the file you've got to complete the file
you can't allow the file to just be
fault I failed it he passed up and that
hurts you if you can't shoot the ball
Iguodala reversing up at the end got a
baseline drive
a couple warriors into dust
such a move on gentlemen behind the back
tunneling one away
Lagos steals get up down vltava catch
this pass lead and knockings we're
missing
but it for David Lee to laying up a
India
for they finish and really by the style
my foot and alters going to be really
happy right now because this second unit
is just
there was poop Asst as a match up hurry
in the quarter that's a knockdown three
bucks one [ __ ] now got hit in the face
by Gasol have a chance for the
four-point play and this happens you got
a big guy on a three-point shooter and
you can see it right there because
elegance changed nice mole scopes in
situ throws it down
for three he's mouth and draymond Green
Perales the ravenna Thompson
alley-oop to Iguodala
[Applause]
Livingston vegan Allah and David Lee
Linux does shuffle pass odd Iguodala
with his sixth assist a vision and you
got to be comfortable he's in position
with three blue jerseys on there
recognizes it beautiful drop-off pass by
Iguodala putting David Lee in position
for the big time
[Applause]
then Paul Westphal says the foul I think
of Islanders - they don't grab dream on
naked olives gonna shoot a three
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
is behind the line
clearly and it is clearly
I cannot believe when Hill got a freebie
there and he get dolla serving it up
with the right hand spike
[Applause]
when you come out of the gate
besides with the number of years Kobe's
been here while knocked away from Nick
Young he get down low to the steel
Andriy soaring in
jettison fall so forth represent plan
will be super took three hours to
develop after Tyler he stuffs
and holding on green throws it ahead
Iguodala throws it down he is so good in
the middle of the fast-break Zig
analyses it opening it throws it down
[Applause]
eight line drive by Westbrook who bails
out goes for the steal no help that
defense will not get it done against
this great warrior team
[Music]
[Applause]
I would say it spectacular sequence as
Steph Curry strips the ball draymond
Green back to him and then an incredible
behind the back left-hand pass got at
least draw the foul there step for the
steal you get down a footrace to the
other
and the foul
[Applause]
beautifully thrown your leading you
don't have to dribble you pick it up you
take that step and a half and you finish
an interior player will get dalla behind
the back you get down the dropping it
off laying it in andre iguodala
then comes up with it Thompson looks for
someone to throw it to the Gonzales
saves drives and finishes Maradona went
down hard tough shots not good looks
here for Portland
[Applause]
come on now they're gonna replay that
keep an eye on he gonna watch what he
does here now he gave me the crossover
but he gave you the pause a little
hesitation can get us some good seats at
Petco for a game okay great awesome deal
he could down all the way
sailing off the steal this car gone
cross-court protected by Iguodala
[Applause]
how did this go in what a spectacular
move and to me is more about the English
that a new doll will put on the
basketball shoot the three it's all I'm
telling you you got a play to your
strengths that's a strength as it would
download the slam dunk head into
one-point game and they get down low the
rebound dragged to the rim
[Applause]
behind-the-back down the lane reminisce
nothing wrong draymond greens
alley-oop oppo Iguodala throws it down
to Cleveland how about $8 here great
feed for draymond Green and does it
finish the basic way hariyama hop
marichal gives it up Iguodala
[Applause]
what a pass
Andre Iguodala a wizard with the pass
play so good at pushing it
Brobee and then being able to deliver
that's just point guard
esque type skill downs a good screen he
Clark recovered a steal Iguodala has got
the easiest shot of the night in the
open floor
Muhammad goes and he didn't get there in
time
the Kevin Durant being out of the lineup
that stops the games of the other
players you passing it Donna
behind-the-back reversing it up
[Music]
Tate bhai Stan knew that Sean was right
with the very smart stick adalat
evospeed
the point guard Mike
tagged by Andre crossover then the
Sunday slam right bike Brandon right and
right around my [ __ ] Blazers up here by
25
[Music]
hey spin move by Andre and nobody and
now it's an eight-point warrior lead
Blazers come Williams fine Channing Frye
fry blocked by Iguodala
Janey's fry rolling to the rim
Iguodala thinks he's gonna pop realizes
the mistake
Irvin goes on Iguodala gets to the paint
trying to spin and lost it figure though
a pushing
and not going anywhere forcing the
turnover
andre iguodala in transition getting
Iggy witted spectacular job of attacking
the best way in the world my good but
it's got my here in the second quarter
smart thought he was fouled leads to
their Thompson cold by the surface five
to shoot
[Music]
King Abdallah wow that's a beautiful
play there
balls beat the Warriors that would have
been Chicago's first championship
because both those cheap repetitive
[Applause]
and through the fowl was able to slam it
when he gets a chance he likes to dunk
he doesn't mind getting fouled there
he's already slammed it down
[Applause]
this is a nice little move along the
baseline
just reverse beat the big man and the
big man slipped
[Applause]
leave and when the big man runs in
reward him Foreman takes time as the
warrior bench enjoys the seven-point
lead like a doll over rebound
expect that finish
making plays in transition defense on
his heels nobody stopped the basketball
file together the Queen has to save it
he guards
that shot is what it's time to eat
[Applause]
be really good to be lucky sometimes
they look at that hustle right there
draymond Green so smart keeping that
ball alive with the beautiful tip to
Iguodala who uses that English and rolls
it off the side of the glass talk about
the pace
[Applause]
when Iguodala did this dunk the pinch of
Golden State got up not the ran up top
[ __ ] dollar grant finds Iguodala goes
inside and throws it down season tickets
for the next season a chase in a four
out of five which means yeah the really
special thing about this place is two
people who are fans fans and by elite
athletes with special plays the other
day that he's still angry he was only
second team All Defense last year has
direct all finishes off the gorgeous
delivery from Iguodala that this unit on
the floor for the Warriors will beat you
is pushing it in transition unselfish
players egg with doll at the beautiful
drop-off pass behind the back and Jim
Cole does the rest i percentage of shots
[Music]
[Applause]
that near tissues foot knocked away
picked up by Iguodala
Iguodala drives gets inside
[Applause]
we clearly got it off in time and the
whistle and Iguodala will shoot one free
throw Rondo pass deflected by Iguodala
big Adama drives goes inside throws it
down was main guys took a gamble by
Rondo and a throw down by Iguodala
thirty-five-year-old legged ala are we
trying to get free curry inside
[Applause]
got it all the time
Paul's risky mates responsibility to
communicate and let him knowing Iguodala
clearly got that off in time juh michael
green with four fouls on Durant
[ __ ] dolla throws it down the red sea
park
Edgar Dawa defended by Shumpert three
buzzer-beating
triple by Iguodala time for the Golden
State Warriors off in time in town in
time will egg Adama foul Willard's
almost stolen what would stop
[Applause]
way more during the year with the first
tee ball defense because when it matters
most
this guy has food with the peace and
elite all-time defendant great hands the
strip seals the victory outstanding
defense by Andre what's up you guys this
Taylor Brooks with bleacher report make
sure that you subscribe for some more
video content